so so
no and and and this is not a
nice
sorry zach but just to ryan's point like
every relationship has an expiry date
okay it can be on on death it can be
six months 12 months 18 months from now
right so
this is not you know special and unique
just to what you're dealing with here no
and that's a and that's a fair point um
you know
i always value the outside opinion
because i don't have all the answers and
the reason why i always like to reach
out in this case to gentlemen who i've
never had the opportunity to speak with
or have a burden with in person
is because sometimes i desire that
objectivity of people that are outside
my inner circle who aren't going to tell
me what i suspect maybe what i want to
hear what does your inner circle tell
you about this what do your military
mates tell you about this
that she is amazing and that she's a far
better pick for me than anyone else i've
ever been with
so the so so the standard was quite low
right
that's the key yeah you nailed it that's
why you're with her there was um there
was a um video i did in the winter time
i don't know if you caught it but it was
me just basically reacting to a tony
robbins clip and he was talking about
raising your standards and
really the question is you know if you
want to become a better version of
yourself if you want to excel if you
want more for yourself and for your kids
and all that sort of stuff you have to
start by raising your standards but if
you're standing you're like in the
basement then like the next level is the
main floor like you're not even on the
top floor of the building right so it's
like you know you're starting from
you know from square one
let me ask this what is what was it what
is it about her that is so much better
than your previous partners
there are a plethora of items and again
there are
sure
bottom line front
um
she's hot period uh she's hotter than
some of the 23 year olds i've been with
okay uh
the
i
and this is not just my opinion of
myself this is the opinion of to your
point i'm not asking about you i'm
tasking about her what does she bring
that's so good she she brings
a perspective that challenges me to be a
better version of myself which is what i
need good what else huh
what's that well sounds like mommy
well keep on going she's hot she
challenges you what else
um
she gives me the time of day uh
specifically we are able to
show you for this before
mommy but
keeping going it's fine keep going hey i
mean whatever works um
i would respectfully disagree with that
particular sentiment but um
intellectually i think that we're on the
same level okay um i've thought about
starting my own business for a few years
sure this is the first time i've been
with someone who's absolutely
actually smart capable and hot
in a nutshell that's that's it if you
want to keep it simple smart capable and
hot is a great
let's be honest like one of the one of
the things that i have a challenge with
is that all the women that i date
they're amazing they're submissive the
feminine but i also their dependence
they can't play on my level at all
that's really annoying right
but so i can understand wanting somebody
smart and capable and who's hot so the
thing is that there are a lot of those
women out there there actually are few
of them are proven though and that's one
of the things that's the here's the
thing about proven
she's proving herself in a very
masculine space
which means she's slightly into her
masculine right which means she also has
a hard time getting into the feminine
i'm not not in this case because i will
tell you one of the things
outside of the bedroom and one of the
things i really
appreciate about this particular
individual want to go on about the
attributes powder that i i particularly
appreciate is the fact that it is really
hard in 2022 to find a conservative
female who wants to go to the shooting
range with you who also
cleans up nice puts on a sexy dress and
you look at it and you go damn not
really all of texas
uh i don't i'm in ohio so
so move
uh i can't because my kids uh otherwise
it would that's a fair point
but still i mean like she's not the only
hot conservative chick that'll shoot
guns with you i mean it's not like
there's no line in the sand where it's
like oh they only start at 46 and above
yeah like fundamentally exactly like all
the things that you're looking for like
i'm glad that you're looking to level up
that's that's a hell of a positive good
thing right and bringing around women
who actually bring something a table and
can challenge you and actually keep you
on track is a good thing like that's
actually one of the
major reasons why i would ever want to
be in a long-term relationship to have
somebody with me to call me on my [ __ ]
on a regular basis right because they
can see stuff with you day to day that
other people can't even your best mates
right even the people that are in your
circle right
the thing is that she is so far ahead of
you professionally everything else and
she is so far ahead of you in years
number one you can get a much better
version of that who's younger and it's
probably more in line with you in terms
of where you're going to be going in
life
because she's aging 10 years faster than
you are
right it's often like the issue where
the dye is running out before the woman
is the woman's gonna be running out
before you are in this relationship
right so you can find that younger
tighter hotter version of her
who is also not so far ahead of you
economically and everything else and is
not so driven so probably it's more time
for you and your family
right so just take a moment and think
about whether or not that's actually
possible for you because if you feel
it's not possible that might be the
issue
one thing i see with a lot of guys is
they get they find ah this is the best
person i've ever found this is the
hottest person i've only versioned i've
found with it i'm gonna go ahead and
lock this down and that was wipe number
two that was also a mistake
i say this [ __ ] because i have been
there done that okay sure
and every single time it's a situation
where i did not feel i could do any
better or there wasn't hot or better out
there for me yeah
in spite of the reflexes out of all the
differences in spite of all the
downsides so i'm glad you mentioned that
i'm sorry go ahead rich yeah i was gonna
say zach like look you know um you guys
know if you followed me for a while my
ex-wife is a lawyer and i think when i
met her she was probably making
slightly more money than me it wasn't a
vast difference it wasn't like multiples
um
when you get involved with a check that
like
women have pursued careers and done
things like you have to understand
something about this chick sack is that
she she completely set aside being a
mother having a family raising children
to build a business which is a masculine
pursuit predominantly right not to say
there aren't female entrepreneurs and
they can't be good at it they can be
very good at it and i know several women
that run businesses
but
it comes at a cost right it surely does
right and it
and when i say it comes at a cost it's
not just like a cost with having a
family and you know like leaving a
legacy or any of those things it comes
at a cost in the sense of it changes
the fabric of their nature
women that chase excellence
get to 46 don't have a family have a
fantastic physique you think they're
attractive they're cardiovascular you
know superior blah blah blah they make a
lot of money they're smart they
encourage you they support you they love
your kids all that kind of stuff
they've
they've basically become
superior versions of what it is that
you're
looking to be and become like you're
probably seeing a little bit of a
reflection in there and you're like i
100 you know like i admire this chick
yeah something but she's also partially
playing the role of
you know i mean you're definitely in her
frame i think even you would agree with
that and everybody here on the panel say
the same thing
which is which is a very bad start
and then you know the part after that is
you're dealing with a
a female that's been masculinized and no
longer a conventional you know
traditional type of female there's no
woman out there that runs a business
that's an entrepreneur that's successful
that makes the kind of money that you're
talking about with her because you're
saying it's a multiple of your 200 grand
it's a lot of money
right so it's definitely over a million
a year business she probably has
employees has been around for a while
you know
know something that's pretty impressive
right
women really look up to those guys like
i can tell you like as an entrepreneur
when you when you tell a chick that you
run a business
and you have the receipts to go along
with that the nice car the lifestyle you
know where you travel to and stuff like
that
that has a big impact and
women that go and chase careers like
that
they basically masculinize themselves
and there's some guys that like that i'm
saying look dude if you dig that you
know if that's part of your vibe and
stuff but just understand like there's a
lot of stuff sitting here in your blind
spots that we're pointing to you may not
like it
yeah there's two parts
that's wide
and there's two possible outcomes here
hey it works out forever until kingdom
come she sees your kids go through
university
you know become adults you know you guys
become grandparents blah blah blah or it
lasts you know runs his course and it's
done in whatever period of time
first step for you
just to really see where she's at to
really like square away where you know
where her head's at and what she's all
about take that trip to disneyland
and see how you feel about her and see
how she feels about your kids after that
trip
one last thing i would say is that
dating is a guy in my 40s like i run
into a lot of women like on the apps and
stuff like that
especially professional women in their
30s and 40s
who have not yet been married not had
kids
those are big ass boxes on their life
plan they haven't checked off yet
and you're kind of like a pre-built
version of all of that for her to work
on so and to dovetail off that thought
one of the things that we talked about
um after she finally shared with me
her net worth
was
um
the fact that i didn't run away um how
many how many times greater is it than
yours like you don't have i'm not i'm
not i'm not liberating to share that
information um so it's not much huh it's
it's
it is enough that i'm not at liberty to
divulge that number got it okay um so
one of the things i appreciate is that
i'm not a one percenter not even close
my goal is to be there someday my goal
is to once i start my business in the
next 12 months to over the next 10 years
to organically grow to be a one
percenter but you know i do okay for
myself when i brought females in the
past over
to my home after taking them out on a
few dates and they see my house they see
my car they see the neighborhood i'm in
they see
my what my neighbors live in what they
drive
they inevitably i can tell the gold
digger like turns on one of the things
that is a huge breath of fresh air for
me with this particular female is that i
don't worry about that with her
um now i know that that creates other
problems like you being in her friend
you got other issues to worry about
yeah i was gonna ask you to zach you
mentioned at some point we kind of
skirted over it that she gives you the
time of day i'm curious what that means
to you like what that means obviously
you've lacked it in your past
relationships and then also this thing
too that you're mentioning that the
young girls coming over and they're
you're getting the gold digger vibes you
shouldn't be getting those as long as
you're establishing the frame from the
get-go because you and i are we're we're
the same age we're about the same place
in life we do kind of some of the same
same thing
you shouldn't be having those problems
does that make sense and if you have
those problems my question would be why
and what does specifically does she
gives me the time of day that one stuck
with me there is one thing specifically
that she has done that no one else has
ever seen including my ex-wife has ever
done um not with the expediency that she
has and
i do
this is not something i usually discuss
with anyone
but
rich
perhaps you and actually i don't know i
don't know the other gentleman on the
call so i can't speak to what other
gentlemen on the call have done i'm in
the process of writing a book
um i was i began writing it before my
ex-wife and i split up she was never
really interested in reading any drafts
providing any feedback
my girlfriend now if i send her a
chapter i've written she that the same
day sends it back to me red inked and
says this is good this is bad this
didn't make any sense to me and that is
a
for like a better term like i'm just
gonna i'm just gonna i'm just gonna say
it it's a tremendous ego boost it makes
me it makes me feel that i know the
feeling my ex-wife wrote the first legal
contract for my first business
yeah look you're in a situation where
you're getting that doesn't mean that
you should marry her though no however i
what what it did mean to me was that all
the other females i dated were not worth
marrying
if they couldn't be bothered to
show at least that decree that that
degree of okay i don't want to say
respect okay but who's who's
who's saying that you're not going to
get there with this one right because
it's still fresh
this one is not that fresh um
a little less than a year
dude like it's it's fresh for the first
12 to 16 months i would say and that's
and that's fair and i know you've made
the point you know about you know you've
taught you've discussed time frames in
the past and the spare points the only i
don't want to at all sound argumentative
the only op the only possible count but
the point that i'm getting at zach is
that you know you're with your wife you
have a couple kids or two and four i'm
assuming that you're with her for a few
years before that right you've got a
long-standing relationship so her
opinion of you from day one when she
decided to touch your pb and have sex
with you and get into a relationship and
marry you obviously changed over time
right so i mean you know you've been
with this chick for less than a year who
says that the next time you try to write
a book or a manuscript she's going to
send it back so eagerly redlined
right again seems like a low bar
yeah
i think ryan's point there's stuff that
you brought up about what's
what's cool about this chick like you
seem like very elementary very low bar
as far as okay she's good looking there
are literally millions of beautiful
women out there that are younger that
are more feminine
uh she takes your stuff seriously and
helps you edit your book okay like
that's nice um but i mean i'm not
hearing anything like
i was bedridden for six months and she
never left my side or
she
fought tooth and nail to get me this and
that and it seemed like it just seems
like a low bar and it's because it seems
like maybe you didn't have
those you have
enough possibilities positive qualities
in these women like the first time that
you're getting this it's like gotta have
it gotta lock it down it's the best i'll
ever have never had it before that means
it's meant to be kind of stuff and that
that that's possible and it's possible
and i'll be the first to admit it's
possible i'm making a huge mistake uh
like i i'm i'm not so
i'm not so self-assured as to say that
well i mean i think it's a little bit
more than that ernesto but uh spices say
uh
you know i'm not i'm not so self-assured
to say that oh no this is the only like
this is
she's not my soul mate how much does he
do how much does he make how many other
women did you date between your divorce
with your your your ex and then this
woman now at least a dozen okay
yeah go ahead here's what i'd say it's
like look moth kind of nailed it on the
head this is the first time you're
getting a woman who actually has her
[ __ ] together is in a total basket case
is relatively hot and treats you well
it's an amazing experience right i can
understand why it's really got you in a
place of like let me lock this down
right i get it
all i would say is that there are
probably better options out there so and
that should yeah that's sorry
the fact that you have had this
experience is a phenomenal thing if
she's the one great you're telling me
she's not your small soul mate so why
are we having this conference no
and that's an extremely important point
because i personally don't believe that
there is out in a planet of seven
billion people i don't believe that
there's one person for you i believe
that
every we're all [ __ ] up pardon my
french don't look sorry if i cut for
customers on your pod stream or podcast
but yeah no that uh drew buffalo check
already destroyed the algorithms
but suffice to say you know
i believe that
you know call me old-fashioned i believe
that relationships actually take work
you know without saying anything believe
it or not the greatest relationships
don't take work don't take much yeah
they're actually pretty easy yeah they
just kind of fall fall into each other
wow so i mean if you find yourself
working
for a relationship it's a pretty good
sign that you're not in a good
relationship so
and
to that point i would say which is why
it's been such a breath of fresh air
that this one has felt as natural as it
has
but even if i were to hypothetically
come across someone else who i thought
was a better fit that doesn't
necessarily mean i'm going to drop what
i have
because at what point
because
at what point is is is good enough so
to make a business
no no it's not fear let's quantify this
like like good like here's what he's got
difficult questions let me go ahead and
let me go ahead and let me step in for a
second because zack's right here it's
like it's not it's not just fear right
there is a certain amount of like the
optimal choosing problem secretary
problem yes i absolutely get it but the
fundamental point is you're only 36.
so let's quantify that
well let's quantify this you know is
there a dollar amount where once i hit
this dollar amount
i'm good or do i always need to be
making more money now has anybody here
been suggesting that no
no no no
and i'm not saying that anyone has
what you're making you you can get some
really nice young girls that'll be
totally bought into you like you will
not have any of these conversations
that's not i'm making an analogy here so
what i'm suggesting is for example
my goal here so there's a certain
lifestyle i would love to be able to
live and there's a certain lifestyle
provide for my children
so once i hit that dollar amount
working harder than that for me that
what is what what's the return on my
investment for working harder than that
once i hit that like here's the deal
okay so here's the thing is you're
looking at the positive side of the
equation saying these check the boxes
and hit my minimum threshold for me to
be able to retire from the game it's a
little bit more than the minimum it's
it's you know you know what i mean right
you know what i'm saying right sure okay
we're saying hey there's all this [ __ ]
on the negative side you're not paying
any attention to no and because of that
the positives you're seeing are not
actually as good as you
feel that they are because the negative
subtracting the formula they're that
you're below threshold now again so
let's see i'm saying okay so let's
follow that thought straight into his
logical conclusion so let's say that i
make a huge mistake here
and let's say that this particular
female and i we don't work out
what what what are the lasting
consequences
in your life well for you zach i'll be
honest with you this is a this is a low
risk relationship if if it has to untie
itself so if you're looking at it from
the perspective of playing not to lose
then yeah she's she's a good choice
right she has more than you
um she's not she's not after or able to
go after anything you have that's that's
if if anything the prenup is going to be
worded in such a way where she won't be
responsible for paying child support to
those kids
uh which may or may not be enforceable
in a court
so
you know there's like
it's very easy you know this one from
the you know from the perspective of
well at least i won't lose half of my
[ __ ] at least i won't have to pay her
child support at least she won't be able
to steal my kids from me or anything
like that i guess you're playing scared
you're not playing scared fundamentally
you're playing scared of it and it's
maybe i am part of maybe mine scared you
out maybe i am i mean
maybe i am you don't you don't want any
other kids though you know i'm assuming
like
you've been snipped or whatever you
don't want any more kids
i have not been snipped um and does
does she want any more kids
uh we we we've talked about it but the
but the fact is that i mean she is 46
years old it is probably unlikely
i have a you know i know my children are
very young but i have a great
relationship with them i love my kids
they love their dada uh you know it
presuming that the two kids i have or
the only kids i'm ever gonna have then
then i'm still doing a-okay
you know
at this point
um
you know i call me selfish i'd like to
be happy with the person i'm with i'd
like to be able to actually enjoy their
company
and you know while i'm not looking for
them to be a mother to my children
because they already have a mother i
would like for the at least 50 of the
time that they're with me for us all
four to be able to have a good time look
here's the deal man like you're you've
got very low
bar here that you're trying to clear a
very low bar and you're playing scared
i mean you can do far far better
you could do far far better he's playing
not to lose man you're paying not to
lose and that's that's okay if you want
to play scared if you want to play it
safe
cool do it you're not going to get a lot
of support from guys on this planet
because all of us that's trying to do a
lot better yeah you want to call one of
those like you know other shows if you
want to get support like yo dude like
that's a good idea i'm not looking for a
pat on the back i'm looking for people
to tear down the plan oh it's been torn
down yeah it's been torn down tonight
well i mean this is i mean this is
mdmp in a heart shell or in a nutshell
you know if if your plan can survive
being torn down then it's a good plan if
it can't survive being torn down then
you need to go back to the drawing board
so
we can tell you've made up your mind
already
and i think that i think that chris made
a good point here in the chat he said
this poor guy's ego is too big to listen
to the wealth of knowledge and
experience being given to what why is
that being happy here hold on uh he has
fully justified the complication and has
taken the feminine role so hard he's
leading with his feelings and is using
them to ignore logic
so that's just the observation of
somebody in the chat again you may not
like it you may not want to hear it but
all we're doing is we're holding up a
mirror just reflecting some [ __ ] back
some of it's in your blind spots some of
it you're doing and i appreciate that
that's why i called in yeah
yeah
all right zach uh thank you for your
time let us know how it works out man
appreciate it
thanks bro hey guys i really hope that
you enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forge
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you